♪♪
[CHEERS & APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: GETTING WEIRDER AND
WEIRDER.
CRAZY.
HAPPY FRIDAY, MY FRIDAY FRIENDS.
SO THAT WAS SOME SPEECH LAST
NIGHT, AM I RIGHT?
I THINK WE HAVE A CLIP.
AMAZING!
IT WAS SO UPBEAT.
AT LEAST HE DIDN'T SAY "MAGA."
>> MAGA REPUBLICANS DO NOT
RESPECT THE CONSTITUTION.
MAGA FORCES EXTREME.
THE EXTREME MAGA IDEOLOGY.
MAGA REPUBLICANS.
MAGA REPUBLICANS LOOK AT
AMERICANS AND SEE CARNAGE AND
DARKNESS AND DESPAIR.
>> Greg: CARNAGE AND DESPAIR.
THAT WAS EASY.
IF YOU WERE A MAGA REPUBLICAN
WITH CHINA, THEN IMAGINE FOREIGN
POLICY.
IT WOULD BE CALL TO ARMS AGAINST
AN EVIL EMPIRE.
IT'S THE STANDARD TONIGHT.
OUR EQUALITY OF DEMOCRACY.
>> AS I STAND HERE TONIGHT,
DEMOCRACY IS UNDER ASSAULT.
>> Greg: AND WHAT?
SHAKING HANDS WITH IMAGINARY
FRIENDS AND BELIEVE EVERY
CHILD'S HEAD IS SACRED AND A
PLAYGROUND FOR THEM.
[ AUDIO DIFFICULTIES ]
>> Greg: YES, SO DID YOU, JULIE.
OKAY.
THE BIGGEST THROAT TO OUR
DEMOCRACY IS TRUMP SUPPORTERS.
LIKE WHEN LARRY KUDLOW SHOWED ME
HIS POLE DANCING VIDEOS, THIS IS
WHERE IT GETS WEIRD.
>> NOT EVERY REPUBLICAN ARE MAGA
REPUBLICANS.
NOT EVERY REPUBLICAN REPLACING
THEIR EXTREME IDEOLOGY.
I KNOW BECAUSE I'VE BEEN ABLE TO
WORK WITH THESE MAINSTREAM
REPUBLICANS.
>> Greg: DUDE, MAKE UP WHAT IS
LEFT OF YOUR MIND.
FIRST, YOU SAY MAGA IS THE
BIGGEST THREAT EVER, BUT THEN,
YOU KNOW, IT'S NOT EVEN A
MAJORITY WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT
IT.
WHEN YOU DUMB ASS, WHY DID YOU
DECIDE TO COME INTO MILLIONS OF
OUR LIVING ROOMS LAST NIGHT AND
GIVE A SPEECH IN FRONT OF A
BACKDROP BUILT BY LUCIFER AND
HIS UNION BUDDIES?
MAKE NO SENSE.
REMINDS ME WHEN HIS IDIOT PRESS
SECRETARY SAID THIS EARLIER.
>> WHEN YOU ASK ME ABOUT THE
MAGA AGENDA, IT'S ONE OF THE
MOST EXTREME AGENDAS WE'VE SEEN.
THEY THREATEN POLITICAL VIOLENCE
AND ATTACKING OUR DEMOCRACY.
>> Greg: THEN SHE SAYS THIS.
>> WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THE
EXTREMISM, WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A
SMALL PIECE OF -- COMPONENT OF
THE AMERICAN PUBLIC.
>> Greg: SO WOW.
GOOD TO KNOW SHE WAS HIRED
PURELY FOR HER COMPETENCE.
DIDN'T TAKE ANY BOXES THERE.
SO THEY WANT YOU TO BE A THREAT,
BUT THEY HAVE NO EVIDENCE OF IT.
PERHAPS THIS IS WHY THE FBI
ADMITTED TO PADDING THE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE EXTREMIST NUMBERS.
THEY COULDN'T FIND THE HATE
CRIMES SO THEY HAVE TO MAKE THEM
UP.
HE BELIEVES AMERICA IS AT AN
INFLECTION POINT.
>> I BELIEVE AMERICA IS AT AN
INFLECTION POINT, ONE OF THOSE
MOMENTS THAT DETERMINE THE SHAPE
OF EVERYTHING TO COME AFTER.
AND NOW AMERICA MUST CHOOSE TO
MOVE FORWARD OR TO MOVE
BACKWARDS.
FOR A LONG TIME WE TOLD
OURSELVES THAT AMERICAN
DEMOCRACY IS GUARANTEED.
BUT IT'S NOT.
WE HAVE TO DEFEND IT.
>> Greg: DID HE JUST DRAW A
LINE?
BE CAREFUL.
HUNTER MIGHT SNORT IT.
[LAUGHTER]
BUT AGAIN, HE'S DRAWING A LINE
WITHIN AMERICA.
HE TALKS ABOUT REJECTING
VIOLENCE IN INFLAMMATORY
LANGUAGE BUT CLEAVES THE COUNTRY
FROM TWO AND THEN HIDES IN HIS
BASEMENT.
HE'S A LAME DUCK.
HE SHOULD AVOID DICK CHENEY.
SO WHAT IS THE POINT HERE?
WELL, THIS SPEECH WAS A
POLITICAL CALL TO ARMS.
A FEBRILE DISTRACTION TRYING TO
PIT TWO GROUPS AGAINST EACH
OTHER.
HE'S BASICALLY MICHAEL VICK AND
WE'RE THE PITBULLS.
[LAUGHTER]
>> WHAT THE HELL, MAN?
>> Greg: I DON'T KNOW.
I THOUGHT THAT TIME HAD PASSED.
>> IT WAS HIS COUSINS, MAN.
>> Greg: I DIDN'T FOLLOW THE
STORY, TYRUS.
>> I DID.
>> Greg: AT THE SAME TIME, HE'S
CLAIMING THAT HE'S UNIFYING.
I'VE SEEN MORE PEOPLE BROUGHT
TOGETHER BY LEPROSY.
HE DOESN'T WANT TO BE A WARTIME
PRESIDENT.
HE WANTS TO BE A CIVIL WARTIME
[APPLAUSE]
SO FUNNY.
HILARIOUS.
BUT THE ONLY THING HE HAS IN
COMMON WITH LINCOLN IS THEY'RE
BOTH BRAIN DEAD.
BUT JOE HAS A POINT.
MAYBE THERE IS A SIDE IN THIS
COUNTRY THAT IS A THREAT TO
DEMOCRACY.
THEY USE ANGER AND VIOLENCE WHEN
THEY DON'T GET WHAT THEY WANT.
THEY SHUT DOWN FREE SPEECH AND
DEBATE EVERY CHANCE THEY GET.
THEY ELIMINATE LAWS THAT ARE
SUPPOSED TO PROTECT CITIZENS.
THEY JUSTIFIED THEFT AND
VANDALISM AND CHOOSE CRIMINALS
RIGHTS OVER VICTIMS RIGHTS.
THEY TAKE THE VERY AGENCIESMENT
TO PROTECT US AND USE THEM
AGAINST US.
THEY'RE ALL LEGIT THREATS
AGAINST DEMOCRACY.
IT NOT MAGA OR MAGA LIGHT WITH
65 CALORIES.
I REMEMBER READING ABOUT HOW
PRESIDENTS IN TROUBLE MIGHT
START WARS.
BUT NOBODY EXPLAINED TO BELOW
AVERAGE JOE THAT HE'S NOT
SUPPOSED TO DO IT WITHIN OUR
COUNTRY.
BUT THEN AGAIN, AFTER SEEING HOW
HE DID IN KABUL, YOU MIGHT
UNDERSTAND WHY HE MIGHT WANT TO
HAVE A HOME GAME INSTEAD OF
GOING ON THE ROAD.
WHAT SAY YOU, JOE?
>> YEAH, YEAH, YEAH, I'M LOOKING
FORWARD TO THE WEEKEND.
I'M EXHAUSTED.
I DIDN'T CALL ANYBODY A FASCIST.
I CALLED THEM SEMI FASCIST.
IT'S DIFFERENT.
IT'S LIKE IF HITLER HAD A MINI
ME.
REMEMBER THAT GUY?
DR. EVIL HAD THE LITTLE MIDGET,
ONE MILLION DOLLARS.
I LIKE THAT GUY.
HE WAS FUNNY.
OKAY.
YEAH.
SEMI FASCIST.
MAGA -- I DON'T KNOW.
I'M MAKING THIS UP AS I GO
ALONG.
>> Greg: SO GOOD.
SO ANTIFA WENT FROM BEING AN
IDEA TO BEING HIS IDEA.
HE MADE A WARTIME SPEECH FOR
AMERICANS AGAINST AMERICANS.
THIS IDIOT HAD THE WHITE HOUSE,
SENATE, CONGRESS AND HIS
STRATEGY IS TO BAIT RED ON BLUE
VIOLENCE FOR POLITICAL BENEFIT.
YOU CAN'T FALL FOR THIS.
THEY WANT YOU TO TAKE THE BAIT.
THAT SPEECH WAS SUPPOSED TO BE
SCARY.
LIKE HOW MY MOM SAID IF I KEPT
MAKING FACES THEY WOULD FREEZE
LIKE THAT.
NO, THAT'S BOTOX.
THE SPEECH IS MORE FUNNY THAN
SCARY.
YOU CAN'T FORGET THAT.
REMEMBER, AFTER EVERY TRUMP
SPEECH ORALLY, THE MEDIA'S HAIR
WAS ALWAYS ON FIRE.
YOU CAN SEE THEIR FLAMING SCALPS
FROM SPACE.
MEANWHILE, PEOPLE RIOTS AND
ATTACKED TRUMP SUPPORTERS.
THAT'S WHAT THEY WANT YOU TO DO
HERE.
THEY WANT YOU TO SET YOUR OWN
HAIR ON FIRE.
YOU CAN'T.
YOUR HAIR IS TOO BEAUTIFUL
AROUND YOUR LIFE IS TOO MUCH
FUN.
SO SIT BACK AND GIGGLE AT THEIR
DESPERATE DISTRACTIONS.
COME NOVEMBER, YOU MAY BE THE
LAST ONE LAUGHING.
>> HERE HE IS --
>> WELCOME TONIGHT'S GUESTS.
HER NEW CHILDREN'S BOOK COMES
WITH A FREE BOTTLE OF SCOTCH.
FOX NEWS ANCHOR AND AUTHOR OF
THE NEW CHILDREN'S BOOK, JULIE
BANDERAS.
HE REMINDS US OF A GUY WHO SOLD
POT OUTSIDE THE HIGH SCHOOL.
HE STILL SELLS POT OUTSIDE THE
HIGH SCHOOL.
THE COMEDIAN BEHIND TERRORIZING
TELEMARKETER SEVEN, JIM!
HIS NAME SOUNDS LIKE AN EXTRA IN
A NATIVITY SCENE.
PUBLISHER AND FOUNDER OF PLANNED
MAN, GUY SHEPHERD.
AND HIS SHADOW HAS BEEN HERE
SINCE YESTERDAY.
MY MASSIVE SIDEKICK AND THE NWA
WORLD TELEVISION CHAMP, TYRUS.
SO JULIE, FIRST BEFORE WE GET TO
THE STORY, CONGRATULATIONS ON
THIS INCREDIBLY LARGE
ACHIEVEMENT.
WRITING A CHILDREN'S BOOK.
THE LAST ATTEMPTS AT RELEVANCE.
YOU HAVE NOTHING GOING FOR YOU,
WRITE A CHILDREN'S BOOK.
IT'S NOT LIKE THEY CAN TELL IF
IT'S ANY GOOD.
[LAUGHTER]
JUST FOR FUN, YOU HAVE TO ORDER
THIS AND GET IT UP THERE ON
AMAZON.
>> IT'S ON BRAVEBOOKS.COM.
NOT AMAZON.
>> Greg: BRAVE?
>> BRAVEBOOKS.COM.
>> Greg: COULDN'T GET IT ON
AMAZON?
>> NO.
>> Greg: YOU CAN BUY MINE ON
AMAZON.
YOU CAN'T GET HER CHILDREN'S
BOOK.
THAT'S HOW BAD THIS IS.
I'M JOKING.
IT'S SO GOOD.
IT IS SO GOOD.
JULIE, WHAT DID YOU MAKE OF THAT
SPEECH?
IT WAS HILARIOUS.
>> IT WAS NOT GOOD.
OKAY?
FIRST OF ALL, LET'S SEE.
THE LIST OF THINGS THAT HE
FAILED TO TALK ABOUT.
OKAY?
INFLATION, JOBS, ENERGY, THE
BORDER CRISIS, CRIME, OPIOIDS
AND THEN AN EXPLANATION BEHIND
THE DEVILISH RED BACKGROUND.
I THOUGHT I WAS WATCHING A
HORROR FILM.
IT DID INSPIRE ME.
I LOVE TO DECORATE FOR
HALLOWEEN.
RED LIGHTING, THAT IS KEY --
ERIE.
I HAVE A BIDEN MASK.
I'LL PUT THAT SOMEWHERE ON MY
DECORATIONS.
>> Greg: THEY WERE INSPIRED BY
THE POSTER FOR THE DEVIL'S
ADVOCATE.
AL PACINO PLAYING SATAN AND
KEANU REEVES IS IN FRONT OF HIM.
WHY AM I EXPLAINING A MOVIE
POSTER WHEN YOU CAN GOOGLE IT.
GUY, GOOD TO SEE YOU.
HUGH HEFNER'S CRYPT.
>> Greg: I FIGURE IF JIMMY
WASN'T WEARING THE TIGHT TUX, I
COULD GO TO MEN'S WAREHOUSE AND
FIND ONE THAT FITS.
>> Greg: THAT IS CEMETERY
WAREHOUSE.
WHAT DID YOU MAKE OF THE SPEECH?
>> WATCHING IT I WAS REMINDED
HOW MUCH I MISS BILL CLINTON AND
THE POLITICS OF UNIFYING
TRIANGULATION.
>> Greg: YES, YES.
>> JUST REMIND YOU HOW THINGS
HAVE GONE.
I THINK WHEN POLITICS IS WORKING
RIGHT, THE DIFFERENCES BETWEEN
THE PARTIES ARE A DEGREE AND NOT
KIND.
I THINK WHAT WE SAW IN THIS IS
THAT, YOU KNOW, WE CAME OUT
THERE AND IT'S A DIFFERENT SPORT
NOW.
HALF OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE
NOT FIT AND THAT WE NEED TO
TRANSCEND THEM BY GETTING TO
THIS MOMENT IN TIME WHERE
THERE'S ONLY GOING TO BE A UNI
PARTY.
THIS WOKE STATE CRAP IS BAD FOR
OUR COUNTRY.
>> Greg: YOU THINK THIS IS A
SET-UP FOR SOMETHING ELSE?
>> I THOUGHT THE BEGINNING THE
WHOLE PURPOSE WAS TO TRIGGER
DONALD TRUMP TO RUN.
RIGHT?
CONFLICT HIM OUT AT THE SAME
TIME.
I THINK THAT -- I DON'T THINK
HE'S GOING TO GO FOR THAT BAIT.
I THINK THIS IS REALLY PUTTING
US FORWARD AT A TIME WHERE LOOKS
LIKE WE'RE MOVING TOWARDS
SOMETHING WE DON'T WANT TO GET
TO AND WE SHOULD STOP IT.
>> Greg: I THINK AMERICA IS IN
GREAT SHAPE LIKE JIM FLORENTINE.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Greg: THAT'S CALLED A
TRANSITION, PEOPLE.
>> WELL-DONE.
>> Greg: THANK YOU.
AND ALSO YOU'RE WEARING A DARK
RED SHIRT IN REMEMBRANCE OF
THE --
>> I PICKED THIS OUT JUST
BECAUSE OF THE BACKGROUND OF HIS
SPEECH.
>> Greg: THAT SPEECH WAS DARKER
THAN YOUR VOICE.
>> I'D SAY SO, YEAH AND PROBABLY
MY COMEDY, TOO.
I LIKE HOW PEOPLE ARE
COMPLAINING THAT THERE WERE
MARINES IN THE BACKGROUND DURING
THE SPEECH.
AREN'T THEY SUPPOSED TO BE
AROUND WHEN A DISASTER IS
HAPPENING?
[APPLAUSE]
DOES HE KNOW WHAT MAGA STANDS
FOR?
MAKE AMERICA GREAT AGAIN.
WHAT DOESN'T WANT AMERICA GREAT?
IS THAT A BAD THING?
YOU'RE EXTREMISTS IF YOU WANT
SECURE BORDERS, LOWER TAXES AND
TOUGHER ON CRIME.
YOU'RE AN EXTREMIST NOW.
I'M AN EXTREMIST.
I ADMIT IT ON TV, I AM.
>> Greg: YOU WERE AN ORIGINAL
EXTREMIST.
>> I THINK SO.
>> Greg: IT'S AMAZING.
THEY SAY IT'S JUST A MINORITY.
THE OTHERS ARE SAYING, TYRUS,
THE MINORITY IS AN EXTREMIST.
THEY CAN'T FIGURE OUT WHAT IT
IS.
>> THIS ISN'T NEW.
I'VE BEEN A MINORITY FOREVER AND
I'VE ALWAYS BEEN A PROBLEM.
[APPLAUSE]
WHEN I SAW THIS, I WAS HALF
ASLEEP.
RIGHT?
YOU GOT TO BE HALF ASLEEP.
HIS WORDS MAKE MORE SENSE.
I JUST -- I THOUGHT -- SCHIFF
LIKES TO WRITE SCRIPTS AND
STUFF.
I FEEL LIKE THEY BROUGHT GEORGE
LUCAS IN AND HE WAS GOING TO BE
THE NEW SITH LORD.
DARTH YELLS WITH SITH.
THE OTHER THING, HE WAS CLEARLY
MEDICATED.
I WOULD LIKE TWO SO I CAN LAY ON
THE GRASS AND CUSS OUT CLOUDS.
>> Laura:
>> REAL QUICK.
THIS GAVE ME NIGHTMARES LAST
NIGHT ABOUT THAT BOYFRIEND I
COULDN'T GET OVER IN HIGH
SCHOOL.
LIKE THE FIRST LOVE.
HE REMINDS ME OF LIKE HE NEEDS
TO GET OVER TRUMP.
REMINDED ME OF THAT EX-BOYFRIEND
THAT I'M GOING TO KEEP TALKING
ABOUT HIM AND MAKE HIM THINK I'M
HAPPY BUT I'M NOT.
HE NEEDS TO GET OVER TRUMP.
>> Greg: IT'S GOOD WE FINALLY
ENDED UP BECOMING FRIENDS
THOUGH.
LAST WORD, JIM?
>> ONLY TWO NETWORKS SHOWED THE
SPEECH.
MSNBC AND CNN.
NOBODY ELSE BOUGHT IT.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO AIR THAT.
YOU KNOW HE'S UNPOPULAR WHEN C